[Musique]
les militants de la france insoumise
l'attendent impatiemment le meeting de
jean luc mélenchon se tiendra le 5
décembre à la défense en plateau pour
cet entretien politique sébastien ramage
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le porte
parole les insoumis dans les yvelines et
bonjour également à celles et ceux qui
nous suivent sur tv 78e meeting que
j'évoquais se déroule donc le 5 décembre
c'est le premier au grand rendez vous de
cette campagne présidentielle pour jean
luc mélenchon il va permettre à votre
candidat de peut-être se relancer aussi
dans les sondages aujourd'hui il est
autour de 10% je rappelle qu'au second
au premier tour pardon de la
présidentielle il ya cinq ans ils
étaient autour des 19 5% un petit peu en
dessous donc aujourd'hui alors je veux
pas jouer au commentateur de sondages
mais la dynamique elle est là dans la
france insoumise vous avez évoqué le
chiffre de 10% et d'autres sondages qui
disent 12 13 le fait est que jean luc
mélenchon ressort comme le candidat qui
agrège le plus de voix autour de lui
notamment de deux voix populaire
maintenant nous on est convaincu que ce
qui s'est passé en 2017 va se reproduire
en 2020 c'est à dire qu'au fur et à
mesure que la campagne avance et que les
gens s'y intéressent et bien cette
émulation politique dans le pays va
progresser et enfin dernière chose ces
chiffres souvent ne prennent en compte
une abstention aux alentours de 30 voire
40 % il est fort peu probable qu'elle
soit aussi élevé parce que c'est encore
une élection qui intéresse les gens
parce qu'elle a un enjeu important et
elle touche à leur quotidien donc nous
on pense que le - iliad abstentionnistes
est bien le plus la france insoumise
fera un score important et nous croyons
sincèrement à notre possibilité d'être
au second tour à cette élection le
candidat de la gauche pour vous c'est
jean luc mélenchon alors nous on n'a pas
vocation à être le candidat de la gauche
en invocation être le candidat populaire
en tout cas c'est à dire dépassé aussi
le simple périmètre des électeurs
habituels et aller chercher des gens qui
ont arrêté de croire en la politique
donc c'est pour nous ça l'enjeu de
l'élection et on nous on pense qu'on
peut être voilà le la candidature de
rupture avec l'ordre des choses si vous
en avez marre des libéraux de droite et
des libéraux de droite extrême de
l'autre eh bien il a une une alternative
qui change le quotidien et qui permet de
vivre mieux à la fin l'élection c'est la
france insoumise rassembler la gauche ça
reste une utopie autour d'une seule et
même candidature et ce dès le premier
tour pour m d'accéder à ce second tour
et pas qu'il manque quelques voix pour
pouvoir y arriver je pense que je vois à
peu près où vous voulez en venir vous
parler des différentes candidatures à
gauche ni le fait est que à la fin ce
qui compte c'est de rassembler des
électeurs donc je pense qu'il ya un
enjeu à faire de la politique
aujourd'hui a pas juste être dans des
discussions d'appareils donc nous notre
pari c'est de rassembler les militants
enfin plutôt les électeurs à la base
parce que les partis en eau n'ont pas
réussi à se mettre d'accord donc
rassemblés à la base pour octobre d'un
programme je pense que là c'est tout ce
qui nous reste à faire parce que ils ont
tous annoncé leur candidature un à un
ils compris ce qui se faisait le chantre
de l'unité à gauche bat aujourd'hui sont
tous candidats donc autant y aller en
tant que militant vous sentez malgré
tout un engouement sur le terrain vous
nous dites l'élection présidentielle
continue à intéresser les français on
sort d'une longue séquence politique
entre l'élection départementale
élections municipales qu'il se qui se
sont se sont éternisées en raison de la
situation sanitaire vous pensez encore
que les français peuvent se rendre aux
urnes pour ces élections présidentielles
on les sent plutôt désabusé en tout cas
bas au fur et à mesure des élections oui
parce que si vous regardez les
régionales et départementales sont des
sujets peints en a peu parlé dans
l'espace public sont des compétences qui
parfois paraissent un peu éloigné pour
coup la présidentielle c'est loin d'être
le cas le président aujourd'hui
concentre l'entièreté des pouvoirs
macron il nous fait une annonce toutes
les deux semaines et on va apprendre à
toutes les deux semaines à quelle sauce
on va être mangé sur les réformes
sanitaires ou ou même sur des mesures
qui lui centre de la tête comme
l'assurance chômage donc oui l'élection
présidentielle elle impacte le quotidien
et je pense que les gens ont la
rationalité et l'intelligence de dire
si je vais pas voter il ya d'autres qui
vont choisir à ma place et je me faire
avoir donc moi je pense que l'élection
va intéresser en tout cas nous c'est
notre c'est notre boulot aussi de
proposer une alternative qui soit réel
au système actuel est de présenter des
propositions vous avez vous l'avez avec
vous d'ailleurs ce livre programme qui a
été publiée courant du mois de novembre
de votre candidat jean-luc mélenchon
l'avenir en commun 690 proposition
salaire minimum à 1400 euros 6ème
république retraite à 60 ans tout ça
c'est des propositions qui ont été
faites aussi en 2017 qu'est ce qui
change dans la proposition le programme
de 2017 et celui de 2022 alors l'ordre
du monde ii n'a pas foncièrement changé
depuis 2022 donc c'est normal qu'on
retrouve des propositions par ailleurs
le mandat d' emmanuel macron tend plutôt
à vérifier qu'en 2017 on avait les
bonnes solutions quand on disait par
exemple qu'il faut arrêter de supprimer
des lits dans les hôpitaux on était déjà
au moment du au début du quinquennat à
vingt-trois mille suppressions de lits
depuis 2010 et bien la crise sanitaire a
bien prouvé que c'est nous les insoumis
qui avions raison de dire que le service
public doit être une priorité que les
infirmiers infirmières doivent être
mieux payés qu'on doit recruter
davantage donc le programme de 2017 il
reste d'actualité sur beaucoup de mesure
et bien sûr elle a été mise à jour à la
marge sur les chiffres etc mais aussi au
fur et à mesure des rencontres qu'on a
pu faire des concertations
d'associations de syndicats on a des
nouvelles mesures aussi voilà qui qui
apparaissent dans le programme par
exemple le bloc le blocage des prix pour
les produits de première nécessité
n'apparaissait pas dans le programme de
2017 c'est quelque chose qu'on a qu'on a
voulu mettre en avant suite à la crise
dg du jaune où vous avez bien vu ce que
ça aurait fait
sur le portefeuille des français en tout
cas sur la perception de cela
l'augmentation du prix de l'essence donc
il ya de garder - il ya des moments où
voilà on a mis à jour le programme soit
certains éléments en fonction du
contexte social si en 2017 ça n'a pas
fonctionné pourquoi ça fonctionnerait en
ça c'est la démocratie et donc les gens
ils vont être il faut aller chercher des
électeurs il faut les convaincre drame
mieux qu'on voit encore de l'ordre déjà
je pense que notre corps en 2017 il a
quand même fait une sacrée surprise et
il est plus qu'honorable donc à 600
mille voix près on était au second tour
là je pense que au vu du contexte
l'avenir en commun plus que jamais notre
programme
apparaît comme une réponse adaptée aux
soucis des gens c'est à dire que si vous
regardez en face dans la classe
politique que ce soit les zemmour les le
pen même la droite et leur obsession
identitaire obsession sur l'islam nous
on est les seuls à arriver avec un
programme qui est cohérent
du début à la fin avec 690 propositions
et des réponses concrètes sur les
problèmes que vivent les gens les
problèmes sociaux les
le fait que les gens ils ont du mal à
finir les fins de mois non une réponse à
ça plutôt que de jouer sur les haines et
la diversion de l'islam des choses comme
ça sur le proposition n'aura l'occasion
bien évidemment d'y revenir avec les
différents partis politiques disent ils
les scrutins de 2022 il y aura aussi des
élections législatives mais sans vous
faire commenté pour autant les sondages
et il y en a un qui a été publiée la
semaine dernière sont un jeu doxa votre
candidat jean-luc mélenchon est la
deuxième personnalité politique a
suscité le rejet d'arriérés eric zemmour
est devant marine le pen donc en termes
d'image il va y avoir du travail c'est
votre priorité l'image de votre candidat
aussi
je veux provoquer mais non
alors le premièrement les élections
présidentielles c'est pas la nouvelle
star donc c'est un casting emilia d une
rencontre des français et un candidat
mais bien sûr mais la personnalité que
je veux dire c'est que le plus important
c'est le programme et nous on dit aux
gens oui peut-être que je sais par nos
zélés pas mélenchon parce que ils crient
ou parce que il n'est pas aussi beau que
et et jeunes que emmanuel macron en fait
c'est pas ça le sujet le sujet c'est le
contenu politique de ce qu'on propose
vous êtes content la retraite à 60 ans
la retraite à 70 ans ou à 63 ans et bien
voté pour la france est soumise vous en
avez marre que le salaire y stagnent
voté pour la france un solide vous en
avez marre de voir des hôpitaux fermés
des services publics fermés des postes d
voilà tout ce qui fait en gros notre
modèle social se faire détricoter vous
en avez marre de tout ça et bien il ya
un vote d'alternative classe et c'est là
la première chose et la deuxième chose
c'est que oui j'en ai qu un champ il est
clivant en fait et tant mieux j'ai envie
de dire parce que quand on propose au
final un consensus général avec le monde
et quand on voit l'état du monde on peut
se poser la question de la pertinence de
cela donc quand on propose un consensus
c'est sûr c'est plus facile quand on
propose un modèle de rupture évidemment
que ça crée du clivage mais tant mieux
en fait il y en a d'autres qui sont
clivant j'imagine qu'ils ne sont pas de
votre bord eric zemmour il a annoncé
aussi sa candidature il a officialisé sa
candidature cette semaine vous avez
regardé sa déclaration de candidature sa
vidéo non ça m'intéresse pas plus que ça
j'ai vu des extraits parce qu'on ne peut
pas y échapper dès qu'on allume sa télé
d'ailleurs je pense que il est
légèrement sur médiatisé par rapport à
ce qu'il a produit en terme de fonds par
rapport aux gens qui a en tout autour de
lui de la dynamique réelle de sa
campagne donc j'espère que cette bulle
va se dégonfler en tout cas moi je vous
dis ils m'inquiètent il m'inquiète pour
l'état du débat public dans notre pays
l'état de notre démocratie
je ne pense pas que c'est quelqu'un qui
fasse du bien à la politique au vu de la
la bassesse du niveau et de l'absurde
dedans tout ce qu'il dit et dans la
haine qui qui qui qui propagent sur le
fond sur cette son lancement de campagne
s qui guidait cette vidéo bien sûr c'est
la question de l'immigration la grandeur
de la france une grandeur honteusement
même si elle existait quand on voit les
images et un peu romancée un petit peu
de cette vidéo là est ce que vous
craignez tout de même que la campagne
s'enlise s'éternisent sur ces questions
de grand remplacement
de d'immigration j'ai envie de dire eric
zemmour il est juste le produit de son
environnement aussi parce que ça fait un
moment que l'ensemble de la classe
politique se focalise sur ces questions
là il n'y a pas que lui il ya la droite
vous et regardez vous allez sûrement
regardé le débat de la primaire des
réelles vigan ou en dehors de cette
thématique là il n'y a pas grand chose
donc nous ce qu'on fait c'est le pari de
parler d'autre chose pour le coup moi je
pense que on va venir sur le programme
juste après je j'imagine mais je pense
que parler de renouvellement de notre
démocratie de 6ème république par les 2
d'augmentation des salaires ou de
protection du droit des travailleurs et
d'amélioration du droit du travail eh
bien ces choses là pour le coup elle
vont intéresser les français et les
médias seront bien obligés d'en parler
et monsieur zemmour et toute sa bande ce
qu'ont bien obligé de prendre une
position sécurité sur ces domaines là la
france est soumise à des propositions
aussi alors oui le principe consistant à
lier immigration et sécurité toujours la
même c'est le camp adverse qui l'a
imposée dans le débat mais c'est de ce
sont deux sujets qui sont qui censure ce
sont deux sujets différents alors sur la
sécurité moi j'ai envie de vous dire
enfin ceux qui en parlent le plus ce
sont souvent ceux qui en font moins vous
regardez ce qu'a fait monsieur darmanin
avec son gouvernement enfin le reste de
son gouvernement et la droite aussi dans
ce pays c'est essentiellement supprimer
des postes de fonctionnaires nous ce que
nous disons pour pour la police qui la
sécurité est une question sociale c'est
un service public donc nous nous
considérons que c'est un service public
qui a des difficultés et qu'une de ses
difficultés vient du fait que l'ensemble
des missions de police sont concentrées
sur la répression de petits de petits
délits de petits consommateurs de
cannabis ou de petits problèmes de
stationnement des choses comme ça là où
nous nous pensons que la police doit
être davantage sur un travail de
prévention denquête et de terrain et
donc nous vous souhaitons par exemple
redéployer les moyens qui sont à louer
aujourd'hui à la bac donc à l'arrêt par
direct en fait enfin
[Musique]
je perds mes mots mais à la répression
de la petite délinquance nous souhaitons
réellement réallouer ses moyens vers du
travail dgt enquête et du travail
approfondi pour notamment travaillé sur
les gangs qui qui va kiki
qui agissent dans certains endroits sur
la grande délinquance sur la fraude
fiscale aussi parce que c'est aussi des
compétences qui font partie du rial et
des thématiques sur lesquelles vous avez
aussi des propositions justes un dernier
mot aujourd'hui on connaît l'état des
finances françaises augmenter les
salaires
restaurer des tva des tva plus
progressive avec des tranches
supplémentaires aussi qui toucherait les
classes les plus aisées c'est réalisable
c'est possible alors la plupart des
salaires sont pas payés par l'état un
double sas et
l'état global des finances ce soit pour
les entreprises vont jouer bien sûr pour
les entreprises ça se passe bien si vous
regardez les gens les principes et aux
pme
vous avez la fortune des milliardaires
français qui a augmenté de 40% pendant
la crise du coc vide on est on a eu une
augmentation jeu chiffre juste ici
tout 270 milliards d'euros de leur
fortune balantine khalid et des tpe des
pme qui embauchent au quotidien les
salariés aussi d'accord mais ça
représente quand même une part
importante de la richesse produite et
donc il ya aussi à un moment si l'état
veut pouvoir agir sur les salaires et
sur les politiques publiques il ya de
l'argent à les récupérer il ya ceux
qu'ils devraient payer des impôts on
devrait leur faire payer mais sur les
tpe pme il ya aussi une autre chose
qu'il faut regarder c'est de quoi elle
souffre aujourd'hui elle souffre
principalement du carnet de commandes
qui n'est pas rempli alors si vous
augmentez les salaires vous passez le
smic à 1400 euros comme nous le
proposons derrière sont des gens qui
m'en aller davantage aux restaurants qui
vont aller à l'est davantage je sais pas
moi au bar ou faire du ou partir en
vacances et bien toutes ces choses là
elles vont permettre à des entreprises
d'embaucher 2 2 de vendre de pouvoir
augmenter leurs carnets de commandes
justement parce que vous vous relancer
la machine économique plutôt que la
logique actuelle où on écrase tous ont
fait des politiques d'austérité qui au
final contracte l'économie merci
sébastien gamache par parle des insoumis
dans les yvelines d'être revenu pour cet
entretien politique on rappelle ce
rendez vous du 5 décembre pour votre
formation politique à la défense autour
de jean-luc mélenchon c'est donc la fin
de cette émission se retrouve bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]